foreign
is in Lexington Kentucky hi Jonathan
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi guys I've heard about you all my life
Dave and I'm going to be the first
person to actually do it
Okay cool so everyone's talking about it
and you want to be about it
absolutely love it um I'm trying to be
as specific as possible and setting my
goals um I'm 25 years old seeing a
homeowner and I grew up 45k home take
home and I next year I have potentially
make 103 000 uh next year take home I
was about six or seven dollars an hour
increase the schedule it's been the next
five years there are six goals I want to
have done in that time uh it came that
twelve thousand dollar emergency fund
start my 15 retirement
um I want a BBA in finance I'll cost
about 40K but I'm pretty sure I can get
that through work and I also want to be
in a 300 000 home paid off after selling
my current one and then somehow find a
wife between all of that debt free
um I've been floating through life for
the past seven years now and I'm
concerned I'm biting them off more than
I can chew
well I love your drive first of all and
it sounds like you're trying to make up
for lost time and I want to just
encourage you to you could slow down
Focus your 25 not 75 you have a lot of
life ahead of you and all of those
things can and will happen but don't you
know try to do it all at once and so our
baby steps are designed to have focused
intensity one thing at a time and that
means having that thousand dollar
emergency fund then getting out of all
of your Consumer Debt then the fully
funded emergency fund and you said
you're already a homeowner
correct what's left on your mortgage
72 000. all right what other debt do you
have
a couple personal loans uh credit card
and I'll be visiting you on January 16th
and I'm going to do my testectomy there
love it fun so Jonathan you said you
were
um
floating before and you're anything but
floating now you're dialed in focused
and intense now what was the change
um
well I had a couple of relationships
fell through and depression didn't
really feel good about myself uh
I'm down like 36 pounds I started losing
weight and stuff and I don't know I'm
just snowball's going I guess
okay so the
the answer to the broken relationships
and the Depression was to start
controlling the controllables and so you
start taking care of your body
you're um
you've uh gotten some help or whatever
and have moved your way away from the
depression and now you're setting
yourself on goals that's awesome way to
go
thank you Dave sure proud of you that's
a good move
um it's um I mean that's 180 degrees you
you've turned this whole thing around
and um uh
that's uh a good thing and then you know
we don't want to ever put water on your
fire you're doing a great job
um the only thing that George is saying
that I would agree with is is that uh
what I've always found including our
business goals here at Ramsey uh
including product launches here
including
um building a a a building uh nothing
ever turns out exactly like you plan it
so just give yourself some emotional
margin that if it doesn't work exactly
like it did on paper then that doesn't
mean you lost and so you know if I set
my goal to make a million dollars and
I've never made a million dollars and I
don't hit my goal and I make 800.
oh darn you know I mean are you okay
then and so my point is the beauty of
goals is not necessarily the uh
mechanical legalistic achievement of the
exact goal in the exact time frame it's
that you start asking yourself what must
be true and you're asking yourself that
I've got to do this this and this in
order to get to that place and so you're
now on an intentional Journey rather
than aimlessly being bumped around this
life by everyone else and so the beauty
of the goals is that it puts you in the
direction and the journey and gives you
the energy to fight and push and scratch
and Claw towards it sometimes you come
out above the goal and sometimes you
come out below it but every time you've
moved in the right direction and so that
just give yourself a little bit of
permission to almost make it or to more
than make it and still say I hit the
goal yeah I remember this conversation I
just had with James clear on the entree
leadership podcast it's coming out soon
and he was talking about how we focus on
the results so much but what really
matters is our identity and the habits
we're forming and the disciplines
created as we try to get to that result
and so it was a great reminder for me as
we all you know head towards our goals
this year and Jonathan I want to walk
alongside you metaphorically and send
you our brand new Ramsey 2023 goal
planner that Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney
and I worked on that will help you set
those goals stay on track help keep you
accountable but uh we're pumped for you
so hang on the line Austin will pick up
and we'll send you one of those gold
plates